I did that and that's where I am there
you can say I look good all the time
that's there that's a reality that's
what I gotta live with we dying out here
I got us Donuts those are so bad for you
oh no are they moldy I mean are they
poisoned are you allergic no I'm just
saying you're judging my food choices
based on a false standard of Health
again aren't you guilty bad culture
photophobia and systems of Oppression
have created false hierarchies of food
and it shows up everywhere
foreign
it's not because those food are gonna
make you fat
it's because those food even if they
don't make you fat
are not good for you
even if you don't get fat from those
food
it can still [ __ ] you up
it's not because you got diabetes
that's your fat
those food are not gold for you they're
not good
they're not
it's not because you're fat you could be
skinny skinny
and you eat them foods and you have a
fast metabolism
but your arteries are clogged Booboo
honey chicken Cherry chop
so no it's not based on standards it's
based on facts let's not even go into
the how your body's gonna look if you
take those food let's not go in there at
all sizes you could be you could be you
could be [ __ ]
and them Foods are not gonna help you
period blank this is not sorry
they said period blood I was like what
yeah period blood
whatever the [ __ ] hey yo period blood
period blank
that's it
this is not even a discussion
this is not an argument this is not a
thing
we're not even gonna base ourselves to
how your body's gonna look if you all if
you eat those food doesn't matter it's
really it's really irrelevant because
you could still be skinny and be dying
if you eat those food if your diet
only consists of those food
it's not healthy period for instance
harmful thought patterns like earning
food through exercising or that dessert
is the reward for the punishment of
eating vegetables remember that you do
not need to earn food we are all
incorrectly taught from a young age that
our size and therefore the foods that we
eat are markers of our self-worth
moralizing food can lead to harmful
relationships of food and disordered
eating instead of focusing on good and
bad choices try to approach food with
neutrality in mind there's good food and
there's bad food stop
stop
stop
that's really ignorant very harmful what
you're doing right now it's stupid it's
ignorant it's harmful
it's [ __ ] up just you being black yeah
just you being black and pushing that
narrative is [ __ ] up my G
oh don't worry about water drink
Kool-Aid shut the [ __ ] up
we dying out here
I got some of my cousins in the states
they wish it would be in Canada
the food is different
the desert is different yeah desert not
desert whatever we eat differently what
the [ __ ] are you talking about we black
we dying up here [ __ ] just
gonna Chomp on everything and yes I'm
talking about soul food too yeah if you
eat Haitian food every day
you're [ __ ]
the amount of oil and butter that we put
come at me I don't give a [ __ ] if you
come at me you're as dumb and stupid as
damn
of course there's a way to cook it
that's going to be healthy
but it's not going to be as much salt
and fat and oil that's gonna [ __ ] up
your arteries that's a fact my G That's
The Boondocks all over again talk about
soul food and we call it soul food
because it kills the body and the food
the soul is left you can't be eating our
Popeyes every day stop
there's no such thing as good food yes
there is there is
there is you want me to make this juice
here for you go ahead
she's a nutritionist
you want to secure the secure juice
apart
she works for Mondelez International
which is a chocolate production company
you're getting paid you're getting paid
boo-boo that's it y'all remember when we
were growing up they were selling us on
three meals a day yeah telling us we had
to ingest all this milk yeah those
carbohydrates right and it turned out
the people who were manufacturing these
studies are the milk producers
foreign
Lobby [ __ ] like the only foods
that are bad for you are foods that
contain allergens poisons and
contaminants or food that is spoiled or
is otherwise inedible eat without guilt
regardless of what society says eat
without guilt Jesus Christ
you're done I love food I love to cook
right I really love it it's one of my
passions I love to discover different
things and stuff like that in Memphis
and whenever you have food you have to
know where your food comes from if
you're from a netting group that has
been known to be poor all right you have
to watch the history of your food and
you have to watch where your food comes
from okay you have to watch in which
settings the food that you have was made
right all the soul food all the people
from the Caribbeans and stuff like that
you have to understand you have to
understand I'm sorry yeah understand
where your food comes from yeah I mean
you have to know where your food comes
from you have to know where it's from
and what settings it was from I'm
talking about all my Caribbean people
I'm talking about all my Latinos I'm
talking about all my natives
[ __ ] you understand what I'm
saying all you have to know that you
were given rubbish to eat in which your
creativity you made good things good
tasting food out of it props to you but
you cannot eat that all day every day
and not feel like there's a problem you
can't be on jerk and oxtail and rice and
beans and Grill and Bannock and fry
bread and tacos all day every day you
cannot
you can't
and I know there's an attachment to that
because your Grandmama made it and then
your mama made it and it all the
attachment to that that grill that bun
and pissy all that free pie understand
I understand you're looking at ulti
Tyrone is the thing you know I mean oh
let's go I'm gonna go in on all that all
of that [ __ ] is great you can't do that
why
cause for real for real
it was poor people food and it gave you
scrap and made the best thing out of it
and to remove The Taste and to make it
better what do we do we fry [ __ ] I
worked in the restaurant industry and
they really make things they really want
to make things sound good you know how
they make something sound good I'm gonna
tell you that's just one little example
a little example instead of putting
fried on the menu they put tempura
because the ladies don't want fried food
they want tempura because it sounds good
it sounds exotic
if I'm out with my girls nobody wants
some fried shrimp [ __ ] I'm looking for
my belly but tempura it's just marketed
in something else for you to eat it and
it's not necessarily good if you eat
fried food all the time
blood pressure will ensue
it will
that's a fact
you eat salty food all the time I'm
talking about bad people and my Latinos
people are all there blood pressure
diabetes is going to ensue you don't
want to do that fine eat all the [ __ ]
food you want do your [ __ ] thing
listen to hip-hop carry your [ __ ]
piece outside and be [ __ ] outlandish
I mean at this point might as well do
all these things because it's the same
thing
it's the same thing
it's not good just know that and it's
not someone that's trying to like put
some [ __ ] in your mind and make it's not
it's not that I'm just sick and tired of
waking up in the morning and watching
the rappers that I lose these listen die
at 54 54 My [ __ ] from getting shot no
no no just dying
just die in their hotel room just dying
on the ground oh heart stop
we lost one of our Haitian [ __ ] dude
I'm not saying that he had a bad diet I
don't know but I'm sick and tired of
seeing all that because we're eating uh
every time I see that I wake up in the
morning I see one we love we lose one we
oh my God
oh my God
we lost over [ __ ] that [ __ ] you could
have that [ __ ] could have been done a
long ass time ago
54. you know what's 54. I'm gonna tell
you what 54 way well 54 is I'll tell you
what 54 is 54 is 14 years away from my
age
and I'm on high blood pressure pills
I'm on a watch for diabetes I gotta
watch what I eat this [ __ ] is coming
I'm at an age where I could reverse that
[ __ ] still
you really want to eat [ __ ] seven
pills a day
eight
[ __ ] that's 14. 14 pills that you want
to do that
do you it's not a life it's not fun
where all the side effects that it comes
with that I'm just saying that because I
don't want it to be you
and it's [ __ ] up
eating all the food that you want all
the time is dangerous I did that and
that's where I am there you can say I
look good all the time
that's there that's a reality that's
what I gotta live with where can I wake
up in the morning I gotta take some
going at night I gotta take something
God forbids that I forget if I forget it
after that you do whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do man
you know we've talked about this topic a
lot over the last couple of weeks and
bro there's been a lot of different
takes and
people like yo why you get so heated
about this like it's not that deep it is
that deep and it is that big and it's
that vast is that why you want to make
all the fat jokes I don't give a [ __ ] it
is a huge problem okay and double
entender triple entender all the roads
don't care I meant what I said
it is a huge problem let's keep it a
stack
these problems whilst they're all over
the country all over the continent all
over the world that's growing okay
they're especially true for minority
communities because oftentimes the most
unhealthy options are the most readily
available and the ones that are going to
kill you the fastest you got this crazy
[ __ ] telling you you could eat Oreos
and not feel guilty I bet you should you
should not because I want you to feel
bad about yourself but because you got
to understand that that relationship
with food that you're building that kind
of sugar addiction all that other
[ __ ] it will lead to an early grave
and I'm not even talking about the
individuals this year I think about what
this means for our community
there's already enough issues facing us
already enough stuff killing us okay
from diseases all right
to
oppression whatever you want to name it
y'all want to add in food
nah
we've talked about all those systemic
issues in regards to like poor health
habits that are developed from like bad
City Planning and lack of access we
talked about all that stuff
but the personal accountability side I
don't like this media narrative that's
really driven home by influencers like
these and other like media conglomerates
are just like well you know
just because you're 300 pounds doesn't
mean you're unhealth okay
okay
cool story
so I get especially annoyed by this
because the ones most affected are the
poorest generally that's almost always
true for these kinds of issues the ones
who can afford to not give a [ __ ] are
the Yuppie influencers and the people
who got enough money to be able to pay
for gastric bypasses to get the finest
trainers to get a dietitian to get a
cook to cook for them they don't really
care because they can afford not to it's
poor people that suffer the most so this
you want you to tweak it eat a Tweaky if
you want to I don't care
but don't come out here and say that's
just cool or nobody should feel guilty
about this or nobody should feel me yeah
you feel bad and I bet you're feeling
bad right now with your legs all [ __ ]
up he had a heavy heaving
can't walk properly can't wipe your own
[ __ ] getting up out of a seat extra
hard every [ __ ] time I bet you uh you
feel a little bit of guilt then
huh when you go see the doctor in your
mid-30s and he said [ __ ] you got a
couple years at most if you keep going
like this yeah I bet you gonna feel bad
oh all of a sudden Diabetes Type 2
starts to develop you will pre now you
uh post
I bet you feel bad now